um i labeled my talk from simple to
complicated and back
and i did so because recently
i experienced this anecdote
i forgot to record sorry
okay let's pretend this never happened
hello my name is simon i'm the guest
i am working here at konigsbee and i
wanted to share an anecdote with you
that reminded me of something very
important recently and i think it's
especially important after hearing so
many interesting talks with new insights
the whole story starts
with this innocent little chat so alex
is writing to me hey i have this nice
little optimization problem do you by
any chance of time
let's see what's about
and alex tells me we are having a team
event in about a week and we need a
seating order which is constructed in a
way that two people
can change places that are never
situated next to each other
over the course of the meal
so
starter you have different neighbors
than maine and so on and so forth
sounds doable
for 17 people sounds okay
what is a little bit problematic is what
happened in my brain between these two
messages from alex it went something
like this
optimization problem i think you heard
about this recently oh yes i had this
algorithmics class
and i never really came around to
applying what i learned there
what would it look like if i applied
this theoretical stuff to this little
problem at hand
and then i started to over complicate
things quite a lot
actually i was wondering do we care for
the head seats i am quiet answer is no
we don't care we don't do head seats
then i was wondering what actually
constitutes a neighborhood relationship
is it only direct neighbors or is it
diagonal labels
in the end we went for direct neighbors
who could have guessed
then optimization problem so we need a
function to
optimize i came up with the following
so basically
if your neighbor has been your neighbor
in one of the previous courses we assign
a value of one we sum over all seats we
sum over all different time steps
and because this wasn't complicated
enough and by here i should have known
i started to wonder about optimization
constraints because every good
optimization problem needs some
constraints
and then i realized
darn
it has to be a set of integers it has to
be a fixed set of integers which are
mutually exclusive
and i have no goddamn idea how to do
this
so i did what most people do
took a break
so i went for a cup of tea and it has
been during corona so
in the tea kitchen i met my mother
and i'm telling her hey i have this cool
little problem i want to solve and this
is this fancy methodology and my mother
really is not into this methodology
so i bought the [ __ ] out of her
and
at one point she told me why don't you
just move this side of the table in this
direction this side of the table in this
direction
and here's a pretty accurate depiction
of me when she said that
because
basically
she was right i over complicated the
whole thing
immensely
so i had to get rid of my beautiful
little unicorn optimization problem
and
took another 20 minutes to come up with
the final solution to this problem which
was basically move
one side of the table by two
and you can still see we have
overlapping neighborhoods so we can just
switch every second seat
across the table
so that's the solution in the end and it
demonstrated one important thing to me
keep your mind focused on the problem
it's not about the method in the first
place it's about the problem in the
first place
what i did unconsciously here is i
switched the problem
from
seat 17 people around the table and do
it in kind of a nice way to apply all of
this fancy optimization stuff that you
always wanted to do
and
it took me actually nowhere so
try to keep in mind that the simple
solution is most likely to get you most
of the way
and be pragmatic and because i'm
pragmatic
i also want to mention that tea time and
coffee time is an immensely valuable
resource and i'm stopping right now
thank you very much